hi guys you guys again con women Thank
You Shin the hustle yes yes so this
movie comes out Mother's Day weekend so
I'm curious have you ever ran a hustle
on your mom you have to be pretty sick
when I was younger it wasn't a con but I
thought it would be really funny this is
so mean I was clearly a child and I just
liked I lay down on the floor and I put
all these heavy books like on my head
and around and then I screamed really
loud my mom ran in and thought that I
got in a head injury a heart attack it
wasn't a con it was just me I thought it
was April Fool's I was gonna be really
funny I didn't understand how mothers
feel about their children at that time
so I never did I feel like kids like
low-key con like to not go to bed like
you like I'm like if I have some dye
knots I wouldn't get Kasich I'd say
stuff like that a lot like but if I just
had some chocolate I could study for the
exams mmm I do a lot of that stuff
really good in this film we see you cry
on command
mmm yeah I never used that in real life
no not a parking ticket like all tears
Danni uses her acting skills for good no
the last time I got pulled over it was I
had forgotten my wallet and I had
absolutely no proof of identification on
me and the the officer was just
flabbergasted that I could be so
irresponsible
and he said what is to keep me from you
know taking you in right now and getting
arrested and I just said officer I have
absolutely no good answer for that and I
actually felt like he appreciated me not
conning him yeah I actually got pulled
over by the cops to you last week really
yeah you cry um I felt like crying I
felt like crying I get scattered but
because I had done a few G things um you
know it was yeah it's all right in the
end
yeah yeah so you guys do a lot of
different accents and I know you don't
like to do the British accent but you
guys had a lot of cool the character
things
ya know knew he was so stressful it is
and good at doing an Aussie accent yeah
yeah she does bro - oh hello boys chick
yeah hi oh it's not bad Canadian accent
can either of you do that oh I don't
know why I just wanted to sing oh god
that's my Canadian accent I feel like I
really good American could probably pick
up a Canadian accent pretty fast but
once again to make it to to do something
broad that is one thing what's making
energy sound lived and that's that's
harder yeah yeah and to improvise in an
accent that's really I didn't want to do
the British accent because ya already so
nervous I mean cuz rebels like master
improviser and I just was already
nervous about that I thought what you
want me to sound British on top of it
it's hot it's loud yes it was